alright let's get started um so you see
room thank you all for coming
um just gonna wait a minute to sort of
see if the conversation is going to die
yes thank you very much
so I'm Federico Sherman research
engineer at the newly formed entity
cloud era fast forward labs
fast forward Labs was acquired by cloud
err on September 7th and I tell you that
was quite an interesting journey to be a
product just to tell you a little bit
about what we do so we are applied
machine learning research group now
within cloud era and we research new
capabilities specifically with in
machine learning computer science
statistics data science that we believe
will have an impact on industry within
the next six months to two years and so
compared to a more academic group that
makes us as I like to say hyper applied
it also means that there's a certain
accountability because if you make
predictions for what's going to happen
within the next couple years people
remember and they tell you if you are
wrong and as a sort of like data
scientist machine learning engineer I of
course like that because it provides me
with a signal that I can use to actually
adjust my own predictions for the future
one of our most recent research reports
that we put out so these are the
products really we publish little books
we even make them like as actual books
it's kind of a cake but people still
like artifacts and here you see a
picture of one and actually now you know
sort of see what it looks like on the
inside so I almost recent research deep
dive for some model interpretability and
so today I'm going to talk about a topic
that comes sort of out of that report
but it's just of course a small fraction
of its and so this is a much longer book
and really this one is about Henry the
eighth because you all read the title
and this is about why your relationship
may last or it may not and Henry the
eighth's for me really is the motivating
factor for this talk yet a lot of
different ways and some phones or other
tragic ends also like because he didn't
want to stay with his first wife he
kicked off the english before and right
so sort of a new religion came out of
that so it can be pretty dramatic if
your relationships are not going to last
we all of our own dramas and sure so
really why is your religion why your
relationship is going to last or not
a question that I'm going to address and
of course because I can't actually sort
of look into it the future and and say
what will happen I should correct it and
say why we predict your relationship
it's going to last or not and so this I
think it's likely to last and so this is
already actually different from the type
of questions that we most commonly asked
with in data science machine learning
often we are trying to predict an event
and then we give these predictions to
people either to make more informed
decisions or what powers a data product
right but it is not so often that we
necessarily ask so why did we make that
prediction right to sort of like ask for
the reasons and that is really what is
that the at the heart of model
interpretability where we're trying to
go a little bit deeper into our
algorithms to understand what they're
actually doing and why they're doing it
and it's a good time to do this now
because effectively we have been too
successful we've developed algorithms
that have become incredibly good at
making predictions but there are a lot
harder for us now to understand they're
better because they're more complex that
is always sort of a there are always two
sides to a coin right essentially what I
want to avoid is this kind of future
so does yokai have any idea why my car
pulled it over right and and sometimes
we are not too far off right and if we
sort of continue going in this direction
then this might actually at one point
become reality and that's a pretty
awkward conversation to have so I'm to
put it to live in a more serious way
right so algorithms decide which emails
reach inboxes whether we approved for
credit and who may get the opportunity
to date but as algorithm Stephane says
there is questions if an algorithm
denies you learn application wouldn't
you like to know why or what you could
change for a more positive outcome or
perhaps you'd like to know if the bank
is ready to trust the algorithm in the
first place she's so real questions
right and some of these algorithms there
are put in place today um and here's
another sort of example that I also
really care about right if we are
starting to make these kind of
classifications we better get that right
because these has tremendous
consequences for people's lives and
model interpretability is a way of sort
of inspecting your model and also
gaining more trust in the in that it is
right for the right reasons and wrong
for the right reasons and that's a
phrase that will come back
we got we need to mono models that we
need models that we know are right for
the right reasons and wrong and the
problem is it's sort of the traditional
methods that we use they don't really
give us actually that answer right so we
all know sort of like standard machine
learning workflow where we hold some
data sorry we never sort of used them
during training and eventually we sort
of test our model performance on that
whole data set right and then at that
point you can see I'll be doing really
well this is really great we have like
95% accuracy or whichever metric you use
in order to do that validation on the
holdout set right but at that point
really what you're sort of see is does
it do a good job on the data that I've
set aside and while that is important
and you should always do then this
really cruciate doesn't sort of tell you
if your model is right for the right
reasons or wrong for the right reasons
I'm for example this one this is a kind
of famous example actually in this area
where I mean they were sort of looking
at the risk of death for people who were
admitted to the hospital was pneumonia
and so it basically said that everyone
who has asked me as a lower result death
rate and now if you based interventions
on that you probably will have a problem
right and if you now can sort of look in
and see oh what actually happened here
in stirrers just looking at the
performance of the holdout set then you
realize that there's a lower risk of
death because from the very beginning
that we receive much more intensive care
that is something that wasn't captured
in the original data right and so it is
about preventing those kind of
situations something else so if you know
the reasons for a prediction it might
actually also help you to give
strategies for what you can do to change
the outcome
so here it's risk of an engine failure
five percents kind of high it's an
airplane you don't want to be on that um
and so if now you know as an engineer
what is the one thing that you can do to
really drive that best down that is a
very actionable insight that you can get
but again it's about why a model makes a
certain prediction I'll come back to
this later there's Marissa - so the
benefits of interpretability really is
it helps you verify that the model is
right for the right reasons and wrong
for the right reasons and so if you know
that then you can develop trust in the
model it also helps you explain model
decisions and guide intervention and
then they're two more points and are new
and that is
it also helps you satisfy regulatory and
ethical concerns some of you might have
come over from the EU it's probably a
tiny fraction my GDP our it's going to
come into effect and part of that is
going to be that EU citizens will have
the right to an explanation when a model
actually makes a decision about them
it's gonna be really interesting to
actually see what will qualify as an
explanation in this sort of regulatory
context um the last point is one that I
like to think about sort of outside my
work I think it also will help us to
develop a more collaborative
relationship with models right sort of
more and more AI comes into our life or
machine learning models use those terms
interchangeably and this is a ketone
side not because I don't quite know what
AI means when people say AI right um so
read machine learning um but introvert
ability and it might also allow us to
have a more collaborative relationship
with models because really if there's no
way for us to interrogate these models
it becomes really hard to cooperate it's
really like as a view and I want to work
together on a project and ask you
questions and you don't give me answer
that's right that's a pretty complicated
relationship to have probably not going
to get very far and so interpretability
can really help us develop techniques to
ask questions to the model and then
actually gets answers that hope is to
have a more collaborative relationship
hmm but he is one of the challenges this
is actually why um now we need interpret
ability it's like we've more and more
complex models have sort of entered our
lives and as they've become more
accurate like here for example neural
networks all the way on that side
they've also become less interpretive oh
and that's very natural because neural
networks are effectively evil they
cannot I I think fundamentally
philosophically different from a random
forest or a linear regression right I
mean it is just a type of model that M
is able to capture more complex
relationships between inputs and outputs
right so that going away from linear we
can model more interactions right I'm
sure we can automate part of the feature
extraction but but fundamentally we have
just designed sort of more complex
models that can more and more complex
relationships at higher dimensions and
so naturally we are like
three-dimensional creatures and at some
it's difficult for us to actually follow
what these models to write and so that
is why as accuracies gone up
interpretability has come down and so
here's what we want its rights setting
the goal point so I'm currently there's
some accuracy interpretability trade-off
accurate models tend to be less
interpreter but we want to go into this
corner where we don't have that
trade-off and that is where the
algorithm comes in that I'm going to
talk about today and I'm gonna say it's
very very easy and very simple actually
and really easy to use and that's great
because it means that everyone can use
it right then I think it's a great
advantage of doing something that is
actually not um so lime is an algorithm
it's a local interpretability local into
a local interpretable model explanation
so that's lime and it is a model
agnostic interpretability solution and
that cuts through the interpret ability
and accuracy trader and it does so by
essentially taking a model that's
already been trained or that you're
training and you can really take
anything you can take a neural network
you can even form an ensemble out of
multiple neural networks if you really
want to make it very complicated I
wouldn't recommend that because it's
necessary but you can and you take that
model and you train it nutrients such as
it is as Acuras that you can get it and
then it's great and then you take lime
and that essentially is a it's an
algorithm that you can use to then
interrogate that model that you've
already trained to better understand it
and that is why it's model agnostic it
really is something that you can add on
to any other model and that is
particularly great if you have a model
that has already been trained right
maybe you haven't trained it yourself
and that can make it even harder to sort
of understand what it does and so it
essentially also gives you a tool to
interrogate maybe your colleagues works
or even an API that delivers predictions
and I think that's actually particularly
interesting um and he is really how it
works
um and it's actually very intuitive so
the bottom row the features that is
actually a data point that exists for
example in your dataset and you want to
know for that particular sort of row and
often that is a person let's say this is
about sure and you want to know for that
particular row okay what is a prediction
that they actually
- sure it's a 56% okay you get that from
them all that's really great and then
what you would you - is lime essentially
you start perturbing all the different
features of that person all the
different characteristics of that row
and you see what is the effect on the on
the prediction so it's almost like
you're running an experiment right where
you see if a turn that's not like what's
going to happen if I turn this other
knob like what's going to happen and you
will find the knobs that really have the
biggest effect on the prediction and so
essentially lime is nothing more than a
sort of very formalized mechanism for
doing that perturbation and systematic
way here's a different kind of visual
representation right so this is a
classification task and I've sort of
drawn out the decision service here
blues one class whereas the other class
right as you can see this is a not an
easily separable problem right at least
like the way how it is represented here
and so we need a model that has a higher
complexity then let's say a linear model
in order to actually sort of capture
this one right so we're going now in the
terrain where we need these kind of
models that traditionally are considered
to be less interpretive than others of
course at the beginning we don't know
what the decision surface looks like
right so we're sort of starting here we
have one data point we know the
prediction the label for that data point
and then we start with the perturbation
and so essentially then what we get back
as we sort of vary these features is a
bunch of yeses and a bunch of notes and
we can then use that in order to fit
just locally a much simpler model right
that actually now can sort of separate
these two classes and that is really at
the heart of it that is why it is called
lying the local interpretable because
essentially what it is it approximates a
very complex decision surface locally
with a linear model that is
interpretable and that allows you for
that particular row that particular
person that you entered to actually find
out what are the reasons why the
decision was made that was being made
where was the shown probability this
high or why did your relationship and he
is sort of an example you can
essentially run almost anything through
it I get to some of the complications
later but here's sort of two reasons why
it is it's great so here you see an
image right it's a Labrador playing
guitar um naturally and then the image
was sort of decomposed into so-called
super pixels so kind of larger areas in
me in the image right and then the
algorithm essentially now kind of can
can look at one sort of super pixel and
say okay what does this contribute here
and this now you can sort of see that
this sort of like it's like upper part
of the guitar it essentially explains
actually the wrong prediction that the
Labrador is playing an electric guitar
but it kind of makes sense right like
that that could it's a reasonable
mistake to make we cannot see see that
it's playing an acoustic guitar based on
the body and then also based on the head
of the dog actually that is in Labrador
right and that is sort of what what lime
gives you something else this husky
classified as a wolf so that is a wrong
prediction but what was interesting here
is that actually the the algorithm that
sort of trained this prediction husky
was wolf was doing incredibly well on
the whole touch set so the algorithm was
deemed really amazing and then just the
images the predictions were showed to
people and people yeah no no these are
great this is really fantastic and then
with lying they discovered that it was
actually the presence or absence of snow
in the background that was actually
driving the prediction whether or not it
was a husky in a wall and there was
because of an artifact essentially in
the in the original data set that was
used to train the algorithm right these
things are difficult to spot and so
sometimes many tools that can help isn't
actually identifying some of these
mistakes right of this again about an
algorithm is right for the right reasons
and wrong for the right reasons um it's
a fun one to do it also access sentences
you can sort of see what is the
contribution of an individual word here
to the classification whether or not a
particular articles click better or it's
not click buy you can look at that as
well but let's get back to Henry D right
because that is really what we were
doing essentially what I what I did in
this project and this was sort of a side
project to UM to really sort of showcase
both the upside but also the dangers of
some of the model interpretability
solutions and and that the vendor get to
this but I chose this data
that which is actually really rich and
interesting data set is on how couples
meet and stay together and it's a
longitudinal study where people were
asked over time whether or not there was
so with a current partner and they
recorded a lot of different things about
these people it was originally actually
sort of collected in order to sort of
study the effects on dating behavior and
the in the sort of a Jo online dating so
there's a lots of really interesting
stuff in there and but that's sort of
its side I chose it because this is a
dataset that most of us I believe a
fairly good intuition for right we have
all have like so if our own experience
of establishing relationships and
probably some painful breakups so that
means that we can use our own intuition
in order to then actually interact with
the data set and also with the results
that lime returns now I'm going to show
just some sort of screenshots from an
eye Python notebook this is all actually
online if you guys want to play with
that please do go to that link after the
talk I think people that actually do
this sort of lifetime work very brave I
took the screenshots instead but
essentially you can like install them
they can any sort of it's it's a very
easy install people whatever you want to
do it's it's easy sort of to install for
Python users and and then really like
you need to basically instantiate the
lime popular explainer object and you
need to give it a few things that's
actually all relatively straightforward
you need to give it just some data here
I gave it just my training data set and
that is because it wants to know some
what the distribution of the difference
other features and variables then you
need to give it essentially the the sort
of labels of the classes that you are
predicting you also need to tell it what
am i categorical features what are the
continuous features and then also for
ticket for the category go once what are
the names of all the different levels so
that is fair but it needs to know
they've been relatively straightforward
so you do that at the beginning and then
once you have instantiated you already
have a train model then essentially you
say I want to now look at an example for
example example three and then really
you take the opposite object that you
have accentuated you feed on the sample
and then also the pipeline predict
probability that is essentially sort of
my model object that gives me back a
probability and that is also one that
I'm use
um and then I basically here's really
this is what comes raw out of limes
there's nothing else that I needed to do
in order to sort of generate that except
for the code that you saw above and for
this particular one you see that there's
a probability of staying together of 92
percent um and now you see the five sort
of factors that either positively or
negatively contribute to that sort of
very local explanation for that
particular data point and in this case
the reason why the probability is quite
high because they're already married
that's actually something that typically
is a very high and it really contributes
to a high probability you also can see
that like some College is a negative a
young age actually is negative and if
your own property that's good for your
relationships but let's take a little
bit of a closer look because really lime
is very very easy to use there's only
one complication and that really has to
do with like the line that I have in
your predict their pipeline dot predict
proper so essentially my sort of model
object because one of the challenges
really is that um lime returns an
explanation in terms of the features
that you that you sort of put it right
and that's really great if you have a
continuous feature that is like
literally age right then it tells you it
sort of does discretize it in two bins
but it then returns sort of like under
32 or between X 32 and 38 and that is
that is again like lime talks to you in
a language that you can understand right
and the challenge that have comes if you
were to now um use for something you do
nationally as processing and you use
word embeddings right instead of a bag
of words approach well to get thick that
the dimensions off about embedding are
not interpretive or like em people try
and it seems there might be some times
but they're not interpretable and and so
of course if you sort of give it like
all the data in terms of like word
embeddings then at that point it will
return to you that i mentions of a word
embedding that are being deemed
important and then you are really non
the white right another example is if
you use an image and you feed it in and
then it returns like which pixel is
important again that is sort of like
something that like if we look at it
that's not really going to be helpful
and so we need to construct
to turn away we need to fit in the
features in a way that they're not
necessarily the features that are best
suited for building a model that's
highly predictive we need to feed it in
in a way that we can understand them
that means that we need to essentially
wrap up our entire pipeline right that
it is part of the model object and that
can sometimes be a little bit tricky and
so that is where honestly I spend most
of my time it wasn't really so much
around sort of using lines that means
how nice lime is some of the other
things for this one it's relatively easy
and you can really use like the sort of
psychic learn as really awesome pipeline
constructors so you can use it here this
was really for my specific problem again
the ipython notebook you can sort of
Sidi entire pipeline that I build out so
that that is good it's just sort of the
heads up for where actually this sort of
complication lies of this and then you
set up your model here it's with a
little bit of research I just used a
random forest classifier because for
these purposes it really doesn't matter
like which model I sort of use random
forests it is not a linear model that
it's not easily interpretable it is of
course not sort of doesn't have the same
like complexity as a neural network but
it is already one way I think using this
technique can really be helpful and
trying to sort of understand it you see
at the end there's pipeline fit and then
of course I get it Addison also what I
feed into line so here we see this again
the pipeline probability so that's
really all that there's to it and that's
nice right because I mean essentially
interpretability like there's sort of
certain steps that by conventional part
of the machine learning pipeline right
things that we do like split our data
Tritton train tests and things like that
way and so the fact that this is really
easy means that essentially you can use
it to extend any machine learning
pipeline and that really is a good thing
to do if you sort of want to get a
better handle on what your model is
doing and why it's doing that just
briefly to look at a bit more of the
output of course from the random forests
I can get to the future importance s
right and that is something very
different from what lime actually
returns and that's sort of important to
really understand like why do we need to
worry about why we should be reusing
line right future importance is that is
what is important for the model at a
sort of global level right
what are the variables really that um
and in terms of random forest edit sort
of splits and early on so that that is
like what is important for the decisions
across all the people all the rows that
you've got a new data set all the data
points right and here you can see that
age and partner age and actually the
difference also in age between the
partners is something that is deemed to
be very important at a global level for
the prediction but then if we sort of go
back to the original example the age
here only shows up in three and five and
the age difference doesn't even make it
into the top five and here you can see
that really the future import like the
random forest has built a model that
sort of doesn't just capture sort of
like linear surface it does capture some
of the non-linearity and so now if we
use lime to sort of build these local
linear models for the explanation we do
sort of see other factors that come out
of it to show something else to really
show that it can be Lee differ based on
what data point you put in for this
particular couple therefore lower
probability of staying together it's
still not bad point six nine um but here
it is essentially the the highest
contributor to sort of what drives the
probability up is the fact that they own
the house so that's really great that
they're just living with their partner
sort of brings it down and here what we
also see is that the sort of a lower
education level according to lime also
decreases it while a higher age again
sort of increases the chance of staying
together um this is what I did this in
the first place is project of course
right they can we do this and so let's
go right so fiction a couple maybe model
of the real ones they currently have a
chance of staying together 0.7 three
percent rate and so here the biggest
contributor actually for this sort of
for that chance is that the the partner
has an education of bachelor's degree or
higher non married live in New York's of
no proning property also it's
interesting is political Democrat
Democrat actually lower see chances as a
couple of saying hey you know right
hey I just got a rate this is great so I
put this in um didn't really change much
so you know sometimes that doesn't
really help but of course what if we
bought the apartment right then at that
point what was really high here sort of
like so we can see the first one was
education was sort of a positive
contributing factor living together in
renting was negative but the Rays we now
see that renting actually now is in
second it's still negative contribution
if we barely apartment of course that
changes so it drops out essentially off
the of the top five and now we can see
education is still up and now it is
living together and so we really just
should get married and then all of a
sudden the world looks entirely
different so mmm-hmm it's probably not
the best idea to now go on tinder and
then marry the first person that you
encounter and hope that you're gonna be
happy forever after right and and then
this is why useless data said well like
it is immediately obvious why that may
not be a good idea but if you use this
or another data sets but you don't have
the best intuition actually some of this
might lead to problems right and this is
a given but I think it's so often an
important point to make well like data
always traces of past activity right and
so behavioral data encode possibly hero
patterns some of which reflect outdated
conventions prejudice or even harmful
beste past practices um and that is why
I think it is interesting that actually
here political Democrats sort of shows
up here right there sort of like norms
of course that are captured in the data
because we have recorded them coming
from people that like a world life in
the worlds like as of two years ago I
think we just when the data collection
end afraid and so these are of course
not causal factors right and yes it is
sort of obvious to us that just getting
married doesn't mean that you're gonna
be happy together
right but when it comes to other data
sets like for example um churn datasets
where all the engine data set that I
mentioned earlier rate yes we are sort
of running an experiment on the dataset
by doing the perturbations using lime
and typically in the world we're
establishing causality also often by
running experiments but of course these
are just experiments at the level of
data and not
at the level of sort of real-world
intervention and so while the outcomes
of lime are very informative and are
very useful especially for understanding
whether or not your model is right for
the right reasons and wrong for the
right reasons it doesn't of course
actually give you a guide for like what
causes what right and that is still
something that then requires sort of a
bit of common sense judgment mmm
and here is really why I also talked
about this and this is from a ProPublica
study I'm sure some of you have read
this but this is sort of a model that's
being used in order to predict the
probability of committing a second crime
and so here on the left you see two
people that were arrested once for
British a was actually just like I'm
seeing like a kids bicycle and locked
and thinking it would be fun to just
write on it and then she was sort of
like said you stole the bicycle and you
can see that like the algorithm team
says high risks causes the other guy um
it's low risk apparently and then if you
actually look at what happened
afterwards where she didn't commit any
other subsequent offenses
Vernon actually did and so probably the
score was driven by something else and
that is really why we need more ways of
interrogating the machine learning
solutions that we built in order to
capture this early because I do relieved
that most of us like working in this
field we have the best intentions but it
can sometimes be very very difficult to
spot when we're doing something that
actually may not align with our own best
intentions
um so to wrap it up the benefits of
interpretability really to verify the
model is right for the right reasons and
wrong for the right reasons and to
develop trust in the model it can
explain individual model model decisions
and guide intervention but of course
there's still the human judgment Pisa
concerns for regulators and ethical
concerns and develop a more
collaborative relationship with models
the benefits is the model agnostic
interpretability solutions like lime
avoid the interpretability accuracy
trade-off it works with any model even
the ones that are already trained even
api is a dis lime is easy to understand
very easy to use and they can extend any
machine learning pipeline just a bit of
a heads up lime works best with tabular
data
so um both continuous and categorical
for text it just sort of like randomly
deletes words and puts them back
again it's not the smartest strategy
though it does give you some intuition
for images the hardest is actually to
construct the features that you can fit
into the model in order to make it
interpretive all because really choosing
the right super pixels is not a trivial
task at all and I wanted to include this
because this is a bunch of other
resources that sort of are related to
this topic so on top there's a blog post
that I wrote about this talk and then
also the iPad a notebook that you can go
to if you want to sort of play with it
yourself the original line paper and
also the code for that if you want to
look at the implementation and then they
a bunch of other like really interesting
approaches to interpretability in their
consort of all fit them in a short talk
one is interpretability layers by
influencer function so here what you
look at is actually which data points at
my training set were particularly
responsible for getting the trained
model that I have today which is a
really interesting one
attention layers and neural networks are
also a way of actually seeing what when
neural networks that have processed the
data they're actually paying attention
to in the data so that's also really
interesting and different approach and
feature visualization it just came out
of was just published in distill like a
really good publication that tries to
communicate machine learning results in
a easy to understand language which I
really appreciate that
just said a really nice blog post on
future visualization especially of like
neural networks sort of layers and the
activations in it and
[Applause]
yeah do we have microphones just I mean
Lyme treats all the different features
that it sort of takes in as an opinion
and then buries them independently right
like in this case it's sort of and it
does simplify things right because I
mean the derived feature the age
difference right like it should it's it
is dependent of course on the ages and
it's not smart enough to also then sort
of like adjust that accordingly right so
these are some of the shortcomings it is
definitely something that sort of tries
to simplify a more complex reality in
order to recover the introvert ability
yeah so first of all the unit and the
way how you should read those is
actually just kind of relative to one
another so if one bar is twice as long
as another one it is twice as important
otherwise as units they don't have a
lake straightforward interpretation in
that way so it is really about the
relative importance of the different
features to each other it is ultimately
because it fits under the hood like a
simple sort of sparse linear model it is
related to the weights and those linear
models right but the relative that is
sort of how you verse interpreted when
it comes to the to the second part of
your question reminds me again the
source all right oh no I remember yes
the way how that changes
yeah I will go back to like another
slate that's relevant here and that's
sorry it's a few back that's really this
one right and really what we're after
there is some sort of like complex
decision surface right I didn't be
interested in understanding that and so
we only look at these sort of local
patches right and in these local patches
they're different variables that then at
that point meta the most for the given
prediction right um and so if you just
look at sort of as I did like in a sort
of narrative changing one variable see
what happens like it is not that like
the further sort of thing on do you
change something
I guess you sort of saw you change
something and then the whole order sort
of changes because he essentially in
this decision surface like in a
different spot right because a lot of
them is sort of like multi-dimensional
spaces that you live in right so yeah
essentially in a different spot and so
it is not really like if when you just
look at two or three examples like
intuitive actually how they relates back
to the decision surface but lime also as
part of this algorithm has a way where
you can strategically pick data points
that are the most similar from one
another that essentially that helps you
in a more efficient way like map out
what this more complex decision surface
actually looks like and then at that
point let the intuition that you're
after right that then is the one that
you can actually um it's easier to
develop then at that point because then
you're choosing the examples really
basically if you sort of look at this
right there sort of some like in the
entire sort of square there are some
points that would be more interesting
for a sample data point to explore what
is the explanation what is the
explanation for the data point right
there typically the ones like close to
boundaries but but at a different
location from the one that you've
already looked at right and so lime has
an algorithm that allows you to
strategically pick those and then sort
of see what is important at those
locations and that can help you to
develop the intuition that you want that
you're essentially asking for with your
question
yeah it's that's great so what I was
talking about I was doing a madhawk is
like there was one couple and I was I
was changing some of the features kind
of like hey got a raise hey bought a
house in order to see what happens right
um
what lime would be doing in this
algorithm like sort of part two of what
I presented today then you pick their
different couples in order to
strategically explore that space right
so distinct from what I was doing
and that strategy is much more suited to
actually then slowly developing and
understanding what that decision surface
actually looks like right partial deep
Lendl partial dependence plots it is
sort of related idea right because
essentially what you're doing here
you're sort of plotting data in a way
that you can explore interactions
between variables in your data set right
but here because visually we can't
process that many dimensions it's
typically limited to two or three or
something of that sort right and so um
that is not enough and then also with
partial dependence plots and we have to
actually decide what we're going to put
in right so we need to use our prior
sort of intuition for what might matter
and so I think actually using lime in
combination with partial dependence
process to actually guide the decision
for what you want to put into partial
dependence was to have closer look at
could be really good
so so this makes me feel bad about
living in New York well never have a
chance they should buy a home so I chose
really this particular data set because
I think it's easy for us to reason about
right and and I think this technique can
be used in especially in settings were
using tabular data in order to make
predictions specifically for
classifications single or multi class
and a lot of us I think work with
cutting at work with tabular data and a
lot of us do sort of classification
tasks and so I think at him extend all
of those pipelines
[Applause]